[Music]
just as the gods fall into a
contradictory relation with the
self-like nature opposed to them so to
their universality comes into conflict
with their own specific character and
its relationship to others they are the
eternal beautiful individuals who serene
in their own existence are exempt from
transitoriness and the influence of
alien powers
but they are at the same time specific
elements particular gods which therefore
stand in relation to others
but that relation to others which in
virtue of the opposition involved in it
is a conflict with them
is a comical self-forgetfulness of their
eternal nature
determinateness is rooted in their
divine existence and possesses and its
limitation the independence of the whole
individuality
through this their characters at once
lose the sharpness of their peculiar
disposition and blend together in their
ambiguity
one purpose of the activity and their
activity itself since it is directed
against an other and hence against an
invincible divine power is an arbitrary
showing off which at once melts away and
transforms the apparent earnestness of
the action
into a harmless self-confident play
without results or outcome
if however in the nature of their
divinity the negative element or the
specific determinateness of that nature
appears merely as the inconsistency of
their activity and as the contradiction
between purpose and result
and if that independent assurance
retains the preponderance over the
element of determinateness
then by that very fact the pure power of
the negative confronts it and moreover
as the ultimate power over it and
against it which it can do nothing
they are the universal and the positive
over against the individual self of
mortals which cannot hold out against
their might but the universal self for
that reason hovers over them and over
this whole world of picture thinking to
which the entire content belongs as the
irrational void of necessity a mere
happening which they must face as beings
without a self and sorrowfully for these
determinate natures cannot find
themselves in this purity
paragraph
731 is not all that long it's not a
short paragraph either but it is a
very dense paragraph there's a lot going
on in this one
and one of the central questions that
hegel isn't asking
directly but is being worked through
in this paragraph is
which universal which olga minor
algemine height is truly
the universal and what we see here
is that individual or particular
god specific gods
are
presented in certain ways as if they
are universal but there is a universal
above them the universal self that we
were talking about in previous
paragraphs and these gods
exist each of them in a plurality we
brought up the idea of a pantheon
in paragraphs before this and noted that
while there can be a ruler of the
pantheon it's not like a systematic
ordering and ordnance of of the gods and
and this is all being represented by
human beings as well it's very important
to remember that this is religion in the
form of art and the art here
is the art of language being used by the
epic producer we had earlier the uh
artisan we could say the you know um
the meister
who was making statues and things like
that and then we moved to the kunstler
the artist as such still making statues
or other depictions and now we're doing
it
in language with the minstrel who is
producing
a work an epic we're also going to have
tragedy coming up very soon we're also
going to have comedy coming up after
that you notice that the word comic
shows up in this paragraph as well so
there's a lot of really interesting
stuff going on here in relation to
the god and we should remind ourselves
of what happened in the the previous
paragraph right there's this interplay
between divine and human being now
there's more emphasis placed on the gods
themselves but there is
a contradictory relation that we begin
with and
the the word contradictory there is not
um vetersbrook
it's not even gaganzatz it's and gage
and zetsta right so what we're talking
about is really opposition
more than direct
contradiction
these are all different terms that they
they're not like
totally closed off against each other
but they you could say signify
more intense
degrees of opposition or contradiction
so what do we have going on here
let's begin with this just as the gods
fall into a contradictory relation
with the self-like nature nature right
opposed to them
so to their universality comes into
conflict so that's interesting they are
they have universality right but their
universality comes into conflict with
with what at first it's going to come
into conflict with all sorts of stuff as
we're going to see
what does hegel say first
with their own specific
character
and its relationship
to
to others so its own
uh specific character each god
has
you know when we think about pantheons
again i've brought this up before we
often have this mistaken view that it's
like a nice systematic
everything you know is in its proper box
each god is in charge of their own
domain there aren't any overlaps or you
know messy interferences with each other
when actually it's more like each of
them has carved out their
space or had a space assigned to them
maybe hephaestus you know the uh
great
craftsman god would actually like to do
some music once in a while but you know
apollo's got that locked up over here or
you know it's not as if artemis is the
only god who likes to hunt but you know
she's the goddess associated with that
and sometimes it's according to
according with the greek stories
according to some sort of fair mechanism
like when
zeus and his two brothers poseidon and
hades cast lots for who's going to be in
charge of what domain sometimes it might
be just you know uh somebody
gravitates towards something why is
hestia the goddess of the hearth
you know is there an explanation for
that well in any case they they all have
their specific bizandra characters their
own domains
right
and they are related to others so he
goes on and he says
these gods are eternal that's going to
come up in relation to mortals right
eternal
beautiful individuals who serene in
their own existence
are exempt from transitoriness and the
influence that's kind of an interesting
thing influence of alien
powers
now there is going to be a power and and
really an alien power
to whom they're subject but that's going
to come up a little bit later so at the
start we're talking about the gods
not being
coercible they they get to to
decide for themselves what they're going
to do they have genuine freedom as
opposed to us you know human mortal
schmucks down here in this complex
determinate world that you know imposes
all sorts of things upon us and maybe
even the gods impose things upon us that
we don't have the freedom that they have
and we're also lacking one kind of
really important freedom they are
deathless they are eternal
they are free from the
transitory
world now of course in the theogonies we
have gods being
brought to birth sometimes in you know
quite unusual circumstances sometimes
you know a god and a goddess get
together and get it on and boom you know
you got a face to us
sometimes it's you know you castrate
somebody and
throw their balls in the sea and boom
you know you've got aphrodite coming out
of there sometimes
zeus swallows up uh some some mortal
human who he had sex with and gets a
terrible headache and hephaestus has to
cleave his head open with an axe and out
out pops athena right there's all
different stories so the gods have
beginnings zeus himself uh hera his
sister and wife have origins in the
copulation of the titans chronos and
rhea right and they themselves were
produced by uranus and and gay right so
there's a theogony there but once the
gods exist
they're for all time they're not like us
poor bastards who are gonna die right
and so he says they're they're serene in
their own existence they're exempt from
transitoriness they're not gonna you
know if we wanna be kind of silly about
this they're not their hair is not gonna
turn
gray on them i mean some of the gods are
depicted as having white hair
but you know if they don't want to have
white hair they don't have to right
they're not going to get pimples
that they have to deal with they're not
going to um now
actually we have to be a little bit
careful with this what about hephaestus
zeus throws him out of heaven when he's
protecting his mom hera against zeus and
he falls for three days and when he
lands he hurts his leg and he's lame
afterwards so perhaps you know what's
what hegel is talking about here is more
of an ideal than a reality
he goes and says
they are at the same time specific
elements
particular gods
notice that he's not saying individual
at this point specific in particular
right
determinant
which therefore stand in relation but
to others
so the question is what what kind of
relation is this is it really like hey
man good to see ya uh how's the uh
you're talking to apollo how's the
prophecy thing going today oh it's going
great you know
how are you doing hephaestus is your
ironworking coming along well no it's
not it's not quite like that
instead what we see says
that relation to others
which in virtue of the opposition and
now we see
the same word being used that was
translated at the beginning as
contradictory
and gage and zetsun being
being set so zetson right
being placed
in
you could say
antagonistic or opposition
relation to each other literally being
set as against the other right but also
at a distance from the other the ant
coming from that so they are and gagan
gazettes
um they are in
uh opposition to each other and then he
says this uh in virtue of the opposition
involved in it
is a conflict with them strike
in german a struggle a battle
a
conflict works fine
they
don't see eye to eye they don't
completely line up with each other it's
not as if they're gonna you know this
isn't the struggle to the death and
they're gonna destroy each other or some
sort of death match of the gods or any
silly nonsense like that but there is
um opposition between them
and you know if we pause here for a
moment and we think about
we're talking about epochs right um what
do we have as examples of this let's
take homer right in in the iliad we
actually have a conflict that sets off
the whole thing between three goddesses
over this apple that one of the
stir the pot kind of goddesses heiress
god of strife uh goddess of strife um
caused right and and you know who's the
most beautiful of them all is it
aphrodite athena or hera um they're
gonna be in stripe with each other and
they're also gonna be lined up on
opposite sides in the trojan war that is
going to follow from that after helen
gets taken
from menelaus
by
alexander or
you know
paris he's got two names
and uh this brings about this massive
you know
naval flotilla dropping off greeks to
fight the trojans and the gods
themselves are involved on one side or
another
they fight each other they fight mortals
they are in conflict
so
he goes on and he says
this is a comical self-forgetfulness of
their eternal nature
comical
keep that in mind later on
self-forgetfulness of their eternal
nature this is the more important part
here the the universal
that is the god
forgets that it's completely
universal
he goes on and he says determinateness
is rooted in their divine existence
and possesses in its limitation the
independence
of the whole individuality
by being individuals
by being
determinate
right being particular
gods
they are placed into opposition with
other gods who are also the universals
right but we could say these are
universals that aren't fully universal
anymore and neither is there
conflict
and we have a plurality here not just a
duality
we have a
whole network of
determinations of individuality of gods
in relation to each other
he goes on and he says through this
their characters at once lose the
sharpness of their peculiar disposition
and blend together in their
ambiguity
in their two-sidedness
[Music]
so each god
on their own
is not quite what you think they are
and they themselves
don't fully
grasp
their own individuality
you could say
either
let's go on with this
now here's where it gets really really
interesting one purpose of the activity
and their activity itself since it's
directed against an other
and hence an invincible divine power
is an arbitrary showing off
which it once melts away and transforms
the apparent earnestness of the action
into a harmless self-confident play
without result or outcome so when god's
fight when gods go to war when gods
conflict when gods mess with each other
like for example you know one of the
prime examples of this in greek
mythology is little hermes who's
stealing stuff from apollo right apollo
is by this time a very powerful god you
know son of zeus uh sister of artemis
they managed to survive the jealousy of
hera
hera is rightfully jealous because zeus
screws around on her at every
opportunity and generates a bunch of
little goblets
there's a whole story well lots of
stories to be told there
hermes as a little guy is you know
messing around with with apollo right
and he's going to learn his lesson and
all of that and we can talk about other
gods and goddesses coming into conflict
i mean prime example of this as well
would be
um
would be aries and aphrodite
uh screwing around aphrodite is cheating
on hephaestus with his brother
and hephaestus says i'm gonna put an end
to this crap he creates a net which
catches them in their bed pulls them up
in the air and everybody laughs at him
look at those those dummies you know and
they're also kind of laughing at at face
just a little bit as well right so you
know
is this is this serious is this play
i mean there there is the possibility of
god's being hurt and wounded um i've
mentioned this a number of times in the
iliad a human being is able because of
the machinations of another god athena
to see aphrodite and he sticks her with
a spear and chases her around right
could he kill her we don't really know
right
so in any case um what's going on here
an arbitrary showing off
harmless self-confident play
but
there's another side to this
he says
if however in the nature of their
divinity the negative element or the
specific determinateness of that nature
appears merely as the inconsistency of
their activity
and the contradiction between purpose
and results
so
we're bringing in
categories that we earlier discussed
particularly in the morality section but
also in parts of the reasons section as
well when we're looking at ethical life
and um the you know the xhaka zelps the
ethical project or or whatever we want
to translate that as
and really running throughout much of
the spirit section
this
incongruity this slippage between
purpose zvec and result the consequences
of what it is that you do
actions almost never lead exactly to
what they were supposed to particularly
when their actions you could say in an
antagonistic setting actions where
somebody else is also
acting or counter responding and where
you have other people
looking on and saying oh you're doing
the right thing you're doing the wrong
thing
backing up a little bit the
inconsistency of their activity
and contradiction right so
there is contradiction or opposition not
just between god and god
but within the very action of a god and
the
making sense of the
interaction between them is it merely
comedic well i mean then the gods are
just what entertainment for us buffoons
that
screw around because nobody can ever be
hurt it's sort of like a video game
where you have infinite lives and
you know
people just get off on hearing about how
the gods tricked each other cheated each
other did stuff to each other
is that much of a god
would a god himself or herself
be cool with that if they could look if
they could look out of the stories
and the temples in which they are being
depicted and see the mortals saying look
at those jackasses and they're you know
they've got infinite power and all they
do is mess around with each other
that there's a counter response to that
right
and there should be for a rational
creature so he says
if that independent assurance retains
the preponderance
over the element of determinateness
then by that very fact and here we get
the
now we're moving towards the actual
universal the
pure
power
of the negative the
rain
something that was invoked
early on in the preface something that
is part of the
hegelian
we won't say method because that implies
a little bit too
schematic of a thing but let's call it
hegelian approach to look to
the negative because the negative
matters it's not just a product of r
projecting it out there
and it's not quite the same thing as the
heideggerian knicks you know or nothing
but the negative
plays a role it's always there ready to
come in
in what is
positive
and this is all positive stuff right
hegel is actually going to say that the
god is positive
positive as opposed to the the human
mortals the
stare blinking the dying people
um
so the the power of the negative
is coming in here the pure
power of the negative not determinant
negation as such
but something else
so he says this is the ultimate
power over against it and against which
it
can do nothing it meaning the god
right
this independent assurance
that's what we're talking about here
retains the preponderance over the
element of determinateness the element
of determinateness is the god
they can become aware of their own
position here
where
they are conditioned by the negative
and
we're going to come back to this in a
moment
he says the gods are the universal and
the positive over against the individual
self of mortals those who die
right
which cannot hold out against their
might
but
the universal self
the the true
universal
hovers over them and over this whole
world of
picture thinking
for stella
this is all the gods and mortals and
god's relations to other gods this is
all being presented as
picture thinking or representation
that doesn't mean it's not real
it's just the mode in which it is being
generated the mode of images the mode of
memory the mode of associations of words
and concepts and actions
there is something less universal about
picture thinking even when it is
standing in as a universal as it can do
think about any painting that you like
uh van gogh's starry sky right that's
not just a particular starry sky
conditioned by his own interesting way
of seeing and depicting it's a stand in
for a starry sky for us and we can learn
something about the nature of the sky as
we could be perceiving it by looking at
how he's presenting it how he's you know
how it's four gestelt placed in front of
us by van gaal right
a guy who's long dead
well the same thing we can say with the
minstrel or bard's depiction of the gods
that's going on here but the gods
themselves are subject to something
higher
to
fate
chicks all hagel doesn't use that term
here
or to
something that's a little bit more
straightforward
metaphysical note vending kite necessity
right
so he tells us and here we have to be
careful about miller's translation this
i don't understand why miller translated
things this way but i'm not going to go
off on him too much knowing how
difficult translation is
he goes on and he says
the universal self hovers over them
gods and mortals and over this whole
world that they're part of of picture
thinking to which the entire content
belongs as the irrational void of
necessity now
irrational
okay you could
read that in there
but it's not what the german says the
german says the grifloss
conceptless or notionlessness right if
you're taking miller's translation of
griff
as notion most people translate it as
concept and the grief and foreshowing
belong to each other as one is greater
than the other right one is a different
mode the entire
phenomenology itself is trying to get us
to a
you know
uh well and a whole bunch of of uh
gryffindor's uh of of this this
development of history and consciousness
over time
right so
it's not an accidental thing contrasting
the grayish and foreshtellowing here and
miller kind of lost
he took his eyes off the prize as we
could say and this one is translating it
as irrational now could it be a rational
yes yes that that
make sense irrational meaning that
there's no logos to it no
explanation to it it's just
necessity
right he says irrational void
of necessity and void there
liara right dear note vendi kite
um an empty space
a
nothing there to say a kind of
muteness
there's necessity and there's no
explanation for it there's no
reason or rhyme to it there's nothing
behind it because it's it's you know a
void right how are you going to go
behind a void
there's nothing to get behind there
so he says this is a mere happening
which they must face as beings without a
self
and sorrowfully
for these determinate natures cannot
find themselves in this purity so we're
confronted with something you know
dynamic here there's universals aplenty
uh the genuine universal appears to be
something
just arbitrary it's uh i mean in a way
no you know note vendi kite especially
if it's a an empty space a lara a void
of of necessity is kind of better than
fate right because fate actually implies
there's something positive to it
and we've got a
real you know tension here between this
rich incredibly
interesting world of picture thinking in
which the gods you know forget
themselves and discover themselves and
we mortals are kind of along for the
ride looking at the previous paragraph
we actually have much more of a role in
it than we realize or at least the
heroes among us do
and then this
this is just the way it is that the gods
themselves
have to recognize and they will
recognize this in the
epic
of the
minstrel
you